nicht
was geht ab hier ist klar nie zusammen
mit meinem bruder sk wurde was geht ab
hieß es
zusammen mit seinem bruder karl schrade
kranich wieder gesagt freunde ich kann
mich nicht so wirklich entscheiden was
ich erstmal grüße machen soll
aber das ist ja auch sekundär wir
wollten heute einfach ein bisschen
lagern wie immer relativ spät ist sorry
dafür
ich war bis eben unterwegs und jetzt in
zehn minuten sollte ich eigentlich schon
wieder unterwegs sein weil sie natürlich
ich bin weil ich damit ja wir wollten
ein bisschen was bequatschen und zwar
wie ihr vielleicht wisst waren wir bei
action haus beziehungsweise ich habe
dieses kleine format action haus am
laufen gehabt und sebastian war zu gast
und die folge ist jetzt online das ist
so unglaublich geil geworden
also eben ballett riediger übertrieben
mir also auf jeden fall wollen ja ja ich
habe mal abgeklärt dass ich ein bisschen
anti sein darf weil das ganze ist ja für
clipfish gemacht wollen die produktion
und das gibt es auf clipfish natürlich
dann auch
und eigentlich ist alles exklusiv aber
die jungs von klippen schon gesagt hey
du darfst du ein bisschen anti sein und
ich habe also ein bisschen eigentlich
exklusives material aus der folge was
ihr euch dann im laufe des videos mal
einblenden werde und ich kann nicht
sagen es ist richtig geil geworden also
ware schon heute dass dir das ganze
geschnitten haben ganze arbeit geleistet
schaut euch an dieser stelle und ich hab
mein kumpel
fertig war betrunken sie sich nicht ich
spiele das erste mal seit 3 ich habe
gesagt ich spiele spielt das erstmals
seit dreieinhalb jahren
jump ist aber nicht schlecht geht
welcher platz eins du bist ja schon sage
ich kenne einfach circa alle von diesem
von diesen sachen gar nicht aber nach
wie vor sehr schlampig umgeschlagen das
ich erzähle sachen format
der spielmodus dafür deshalb dachten wir
uns wir müssen schon etwas aufnehmen
trotzdem wollt ihr euch was cool ist
zeigen deshalb habe ich dings
organisiert dass ich müssen was zu eigen
macht und deshalb zeigt hört die welt
kennen das wirklichen gefahren
es ist ein bisschen gefahren hat nicht
den ganzen tag die kapern für uns
richtig gehört und da sind richtig geile
sache nach oben gekommen
übrigens ist gab auch einen sieger
natürlich haben rennen gemacht gegen an
der ja klar das waren versus also da gab
es alles wir haben uns gerammt
was labert der tüte was labert der
übertriebene typ aber es ist auf jeden
fall richtig geil geworden also die
aufnahme an sich haben richtig spaß
gemacht und dann hat das team was das
geschnitten hat noch mal richtig richtig
geile sau raus geholt
ich liebe die jungs auf die gemacht
sehen war ich ja freunde das war sowieso
aus so running gag ich mich war er fünf
tage mit dem team unterwegs und wir
haben da gedreht
folge die gas und natürlich die ganze
folge verlinkt euch natürlich auch wenn
euch der trailer dann später luft
gemacht hat ich war fünf tage mit dem
team unterwegs für unterschiedliche
drews mit die fashion mit luca peterle
sonst was und ich habe halt mein job war
irgendwie so gewiss ja ich bin ein
großer fan von schlechten wortspielen
und mein job war wirklich alles alles
was irgendwie erdenklich ist in einem
foulspiel zu verpacken und den leuten zu
erzählen dann im turm zu lachen die
letzten tage waren die echt hart bei mir
hat genervt sowie ohne hab ich einen
nachschlag
na ja also das lohnt sich auf jeden fall
auch aus zu checken wie gewicht was
gesagt habe dass es exklusiv auf
clipfish aber ich glaube in ein paar
wochen ist gibt es diese exklusivität
nicht mehr und dann kommt auch auf
meinen kanal aber natürlich wenn ihr
schon ganz mit am start sein wollt 66
nicht okay irgendwie ich glaube ich bin
ich ganz gut am eingang an sein
wie geht denn das ohne biss ohne bild
was springst du denn da ohne milch heute
gesehen heute gab es wieder ordentlich
philosophie
ich weiß nicht zunächst gab ordentlich
trainer philosophie philosophie bitte
von yamanas hat er geschrieben leute
halt weiter eigentlich ganz billige also
ganz sinnvolle sachen durchsetzt von der
einen oder anderen wie sagt man noch
englisch englische fremdwort
als auch was dafür noch probieren dies
eine zu werten da vorne aber viel lieber
ja doch finish einfach chefs schlecht
vorne will ich eigentlich fliegen okay
so viel dazu egal wir sind ja in einem
team freunde das wusste ich ja von
anfang an und deshalb wäre komplett
vorbeck stich habe man in sachen noch
nicht angezogen von batch den arm
verändert hat sich von mir verändert vor
mir vor meinen eigenen augen vegetiert
der plötzlich redet er tatsächlich glaub
ich schwimm so derart der verdammte sind
als team aber wir sind als team bei mir
das wirst du das was du ich hab
eigentlich ab 1
von meinen verfolgung von den verfolgern
aus der andere hinter mir her ist er ein
herz voller rüstung fluss die akkus also
ich kann auch nicht auspressen
wir möchten uns gerade auch sagen kann
leider nicht ich bräuchte noch eine
rüstung und heute spanier machen ich hab
ein schwert und was willst du machen
weiter wie geht das noch nicht sagen oh
ich bin noch mal gestorben
was wir zu machen wo ich komme in eine
stadt mit einem benz 500 alles [ __ ]
werden nass oder so ok freunde
damit ist auch wieder fsk 18
alter bitte nicht wo ich den jetzt nicht
ins netz freundlich bin ich auf meinem
level wobei ich sagen muss irgendwie
lief es doch ganz gut aber da ja nicht
ich kann er
dieser kommt einfach zum abschluss
behaupte ich mal der ist aber auch gut
ich renne mal ein bisschen paar runden
vielleicht kannst du mich und ich habe
noch ein leben ein leben ja warte ich
einleben fünf herzen
ich bin gerade beim großen schiff ganz
grob ich probiere den typen bislang
zugegeben nicht ist hier nichts ich bin
ja nicht wir sind ja nicht so oder so
jetzt können dir einfach die lobby hat
mir mit einem halben herz bekommt auch
junge übertreibe nicht wenn ich da bin
ja schon gar nicht geben bitte keinen
spaß hat nichts in der hand lieber nicht
wobei ich habe jetzt schon drin kallas
weiter session dann wird die folgen des
super was ich kann ich rausgehen was mit
mir reden aber kann es nachlesen kann
man hier unterirdisch gehen innenstadt
es wird nichts
alter den fcs konnte noch raus muss sie
papanek erkenne ich fühle mich einfach
sie selbst eine zeile voll verschwindet
ich habe gesagt das machen warum dein
alter ich habe ihn getötet ok verbrechen
überhaupt noch einiges netz stück habe
ich zu doktor feld bekommen durch das
durch seine gehirnzellen verliert als ob
wir einen baum steht man muss er muss er
jetzt klarstellen weil ich immer älter
geschätzt werde
ohne bild ist letztens das regt mich
immer auch wenn leute sagen dass max
älter ist als ich es einfach nicht wahr
als ob ich schlecht kann man seine zu
zweit im baum beide nur noch an den
personal und was ist dass diese folge
habe ich dann habe ich den udo in den
zwerg und wann ich muss ich direkt nach
dem video weiter zu einer wilden fahrt
zu einer geburtstagsparty von einer
freundin und deshalb müsst ihr leider
euch klar kommen
meta content in der hohl ist von unten
nicht machen
das kann ich nichts machen nein nein
nein nein
okay okay leute dann seht ihr jetzt in
trader heute die frist
ich bin bereit dafür dass du verlierst
ich habe einfach mein vater vielleicht
hatte ich bin auf risiko bereit
ich bin jung und leichtsinnig aber ich
sehe schon so die headlines kleiner
bruder zerstört große oder auf der
kartbahn kleiner bruder triumphiert
größere oder liegt eine ecke und weint
kleiner bruder tritt auf ihn schauen
einfach welt - führende messe ist etwas
kleiner
klein im leben groß auf der parkbank
ich hoffe euch hat das ganze gefallen
checkt sk aus der ist natürlich verlinkt
und die action at what was auch alles
und eine beschreibung macht's gut bis
zum nächsten und tschüss